oui bien sûr c'est une bonne nouvelle il
ya plusieurs bonnes nouvelles la bonne
nouvelle d'abord c'est que ceux qui
disaient le ps est mort moi quand
quarantaine de milliers de militants
viennent physiquement peu de partis font
ça hein
mais non on fait des clics on adhère
comme ça sans cotisation la fois à jour
de cotisations elles sont sérieuses au
pari socialiste plus de 200 au congrès
de reims c'est une évidence que nous
avons en semi lawrence et qui va nier
ici en tous les cas pas moi le fait que
nous sommes sortis très affaibli
très malade à tel point que il faut une
renaissance et pas seulement une
reconstruction où il ya mais il y a
quarante mille militants des milliers
d'élus qui sont là qui existe qui
viennent physiquement voter s'intéresser
à un débat politique
donc c'est pas mort c'est même l'un
vertes pour moi c'est le bourgeon d'un
bras temps de la renaissance socialiste
qui s'annonce et est en plus deuxième
bonne nouvelle
olivier faur je pense était celui qui
rassemblait vous savez ceux qui sont
restés socialiste justement sont peu
nombreux d'où le pays
donc ce succès déjà presque un grand
courant par rapport à la société
reconnue dans kirby coeur donc s'amuser
à se redynamiser loire justement alors
déjà rassemblé le parti vous l'avez dit
puis élargir sa base de légitimité en
assure d'abord en faisant travailler
ensemble les socialistes parce que les
quatre candidats peuvent travailler
ensemble et vous savez il faut d'abord
reconstruire un collectif notre dette a
été un peu décapité donc ça c'est du
travail vers émerger de nouvelles têtes
et on peut pas sans arrêt demandé le
renouvellement en disant il n'est pas
assez connue en farr bon c'est si on
veut du renouvellement c'est des
nouvelles têtes donc olivier faure n'est
pas l'année de la dernière pluie il a
une expérience
mais surtout c'est sa volonté de
rassembler et sa capacité que j'ai senti
déjà à rassembler des gens assez
différents et des territoires en partant
de la base que que j'ai soutenu je suis
très content qu'il était ce score en
plus dans ma propre section aussi ou
a fait près de 60% donc à tous les
niveaux ce matin je suis satisfait parce
que on pouvait avoir peur d'un congrès
qui se passent mal avec notre
participation avec beaucoup de dérision
et bien c'est une très bonne nouvelle il
ya un sondage qui était dur pour le ps
cette semaine 62% des français qui ont
une mauvaise image du ps c'est à égalité
avec le front national le pire la pire
image pour un parti politique au sein de
l'opinion publique s'il y avait une
chose à faire une chose pour redorer
l'image du ps selon vous david assouline
qu'est ce que ce serait
c'est travail et reconstruire cette
confiance papa faire le bilan de notre
exercice du pouvoir parce que pour nous
refaire confiance il faudra qu'on dise
qu'on va changer dans la méthode c'est
être humble et puis travailler à faire
des nouvelles propositions et pas
seulement des nouvelles propositions
face à celle du pouvoir en place mais à
penser un projet de société sur les
questions essentielles des grandes
mutations sur lesquels il ya peu de 2,2
de vraies perspectives solides sur la
révolution écologique il faut faire le
fait que pour nous le social maintenant
doit être complètement liés à l'écologie
et qu'il n'ya pas d'écologie son social
il n'y a pas de socialisme et écologie
mais il ya aussi sur les grands défis
démographiques sur la révolution
technologique
il ya une révolution du travail et donc
il faut repenser les outils delà de la
solidarité sociale qui s'est construite
à partir d'une autre organisation du
travail là-dessus iphone
on pensait et travailler